gr
yes is the battlefield and walls
these are government troops supported
and financed by the united states
and losing ground to communist groups
many of them from north vietnam
fighting in remote mountains in an
obscure corner of a
it looks and psalms
just when the united states is gradually
pulling out of vietnam
there is a rush of concern that the
walls may become another vietnam
not sold says the administration and
says why
wilbur's knew a little bit up in this
book
remove learned one lesson that is that
we're not going to put in
uh... religion was the
in mainland of asia again
we're not going to send american troops
there
and we certainly are going to do it
mostly of a american public and the kind
of term limits
but the assurances from the secretaries
of state and defense mile from the
president himself
have not silenced congressional concern
this whole problem gets down to the fact
that uh...
for the last year or so we've been
heavily
uh...
the escalating the undeclared
in viet nam
at the same time we've been
heavily escalating not only the
undeclared but beyond this cold war in
laos
and that this is the type of character
of uh...
development and democracy that i think
of the very very dangerous indeed
the concern of the congress
the dilemma of the administration
the situation in the never never land of
ours
these are the subject
so far broadcast
piece-by-piece
the story of the american involvement in
that war in laos is coming up
friday the president reported sixty
seven thousand north vietnamese troops
now there
yesterday the white house said that it
will issue a regular up-to-date account
of u_s_ casualties in laos
today american jets from thailand and
from carriers in the gulf of tonkin
continued to fly a heavy schedule of
missions against the north vietnamese
and pop that lyle whose vanguard as now
push to within fourteen miles of the
royal capital of along prep back
in the administrative capital gantry on
the prime ministers of on a full month
is waiting for the delivery of the peace
demands of his half
brother and antagonized
the communist prints of them upon
after years of secrecy in silence
we are now returning
about law
less than six months ago when the
president was first asked about laos
he left more funds that
than he really
there are no
american combat forces in law
we have been
uh... providing logistical support and
some training
for the new deal was done
in order to avoid
lyle's falling under
communist domination
as far as american mandal
involves concern
there are none there at the present time
on a combat v_'s
we do have a real weaknesses
we do have perhaps some other actors
design of the steps of other activities
at this time
rat poison in september
but last week
pressure and what he called grossly
inaccurate reports
cause the president to discuss after all
those matters in a lengthy statement
he still did not tell all
the president disclosed no precise
figures on the dimensions of american
air power being used in laos
no accounting of the cost of our support
estimated at several hundred million
dollars a year
no definition of the
degree of command
as distinct from advisory functions
exercise by americans that
inevitably the presidential statement on
lyle's has raised many questions
as many as a dancer
the questions clearly derive from
continued congressional and public
uneasiness over the war in vietnam
wallace
is that the other of that war
it could hardly be otherwise
four up follows a mile
the borders of laos
march with those of north vietnam
for a further three hundred miles
wallace borders on south vietnam
that's the geographical explanation for
the whole chain and trail
along which president nixon says
off of the men and supplies of the war
in south vietnam are infiltrated
in addition
while shares
two hundred and sixty four miles of
border in the north with communist china
and another
thousand-mile
to the west with threatened pilot
to it's all things
the strategic implications are clear
any change in the status of lyle's must
send tremors throughout the entire era
moreover laos is terribly vault
here's a country
larger than great britain
with a population of less than three
million people
whenever it suits them bleed more
numerous and more like north vietnamese
move into laos and it's been so the
number the last five hundred years
particularly during the recent years of
the war in vietnam
to control the border areas of wallace
was absolutely essential to north
vietnam strapped
step back only nine years in history
and you find it was lols even more than
vietnam itself
that was the most important foreign
policy problem to a newly elected
president
the security of all southeast asia
will be endangered
if laos loses
it's neutral independence
its own safety runs with the safety of
us all
in real-time with me
observed by all
i want to make it clear the american
people
and a wall the world
that all we want to laos is
not war
equally neutral government
not a cold war pauline
a settlement concluded at the conference
table
and not on the battlefield
na what president kennedy dead about
lawless
was to get
an international agreement
to cool things off
spruced up in nineteen sixty one one
thing they agreed on was not
to let lawless become an active theater
of war
was the geneva accords of nineteen sixty
two
signed by fourteen countries including
the united states
communist china
and north vietnam
these agreements provided for a neutral
lyle's governed by eight coalition of
three princes
representing the three main factions
boardroom
with conservative
sovann off long
the communists
and the neutral isps ivana former who
became printed
the agreements also called for the
withdrawal of all foreign military
personnel
the united states fueling fold-out at
six hundred and sixty-six advisers
but the north vietnamese only remove the
pope and forty of their six thousand
troops in law
thereafter subh on oblong and the
communists
walked out of the coalition government
and with their profit while forces
stiffen the by increasing numbers of
north vietnamese regulars
they've been holding two-thirds of the
country and a quarter of the laotians
population ever since
the purely laotian forces
on either side are generally considered
mediocre and on aggressive
the best on the government side
are they clandestine army commanded by
general wrong pol
fully paid equipped and advised by the
united states
the popped up lol
although trained in north vietnamese
tactics and equipped with russian and
chinese weapons
are not considered very formidable
people
left to themselves the opposing lotion
forces would probably cancel each other
out
crucial factor in the equation
is the sixty seven thousand north
vietnamese regulars president nixon says
are involves small
indirect violation the president says of
the nineteen sixty two june eva read
in spite of american equipment
advice and above all airpower
the north vietnamese hold the military
initiative involves today
united states is said to be flying an
average of
five hundred air sorties a day sometimes
as many as twenty thousand a month
against targets in laos
most of these strikes come from
u_s_ bases across the mekong
in thailand
white house that we made our first
b_-fifty twos fright last month
but u_s_ airpower has still
not been enough
to do more then slow down the north
vietnamese forces
in the past couple of weeks they've
moved
deeper into government territory than
they ever had
bernard kalb
reports on the resulting situation
and what it means
wells has a way of vanishing for a few
months each year
that's usually when the monsoon rains
begin about may that's when the war dies
down when the world forgets that allows
even exists
but then with a dry season one side or
the other starts up the war again and
laos recovers so to speak
and that's the situation right now
the north vietnamese had just retaking
the strategic
plane of jars
these are allowed to do with refugees
being evacuated just before the
communist moved in
the most tragic victims of the seesaw
not-so-secret war allows for the
refugees
the official estimate is at about one
part of the every four miles has been a
refugee more than six hundred thousand
of them
some have been refugees more than one
blouse has the most displaced national
population in the world
some of these while refugees were
relieved to get away from the war but
there are reports that somewhere
encouraged to go
to deny the communist government power
of these people
what goes through the minds of these
refugees
well i've talked with hundreds of
refugees from towns in village will over
northeast amounts in the last six months
what they talked most about his american
bombing
being told by the male soldiers of the
royal of government site to leave their
villages
and having to do porter rich that is
carrying arms and true trip out that
well soldiers
putting the most concerned about is the
bombing
and particularly markham bombing
until nineteen sixty seven while bombing
thirty twenty eighths outnumbered
greater than american market
but starting in nineteen sixty eight in
particular in nineteen sixty nine after
president johnson
stopped the bombing north vietnam in
diverted bridgette's into laos
american bombing has been a constant
then night for a further refugees
they say that the planes came over all
the time shattered everything
buffalo's houses rice fields schools
they say that their report mary bombs
the palm phosphorus and interpersonal
bombs
they all say that they've lived last two
years
mostly underground
what about american
military fighter bombers planes
operating out of thailand attacking
north vietnamese positions in northeast
loves
cameraman on that
or have no comment on that at all
we are
armed reconnaissance but that has
nothing to do
roaming around a comment on reports of
an escalated the american military
commitment
larger bombers b_-fifty twos operating
could you comment on any of its ur but
just one issue
come and we have no
our military assistance and material
is being supplied pursuant to works
of the role of government
and incontinence with the europeans and
americans
parishioner
uh... request an item is a shame of
american military involvement what would
be the official american apply here sir
certain in november
thank you very much progress
the official american establishment
allows is very much on the defensive on
these sensitive matters
but one american reporter base to be in
tian recently managed to slip into
long-chain the top-secret c_i_a_
supported base for furor operations
against the communists
basically long-chain is a logistics base
they fly things and then big clients and
fly them out to the front
small appliances include soldiers
we saw half a dozen transport planes
that d_c_-three scarab lose
the stricken take bigger ones
we saw that it doesn't see twenty-eight
unmarked single-engine propeller bombs
these are flown by lower and male pilots
but the americans do all the maintenance
and these planes are part of a
that runs out of thailand sohn american
pilot shuttling back and forth
the real thing they want to keep secret
there most of all is that the u_s_ air
force ones jolly green giant rescue
helicopters
this is
uh... an admission that the u_s_ bombs
last them you can hear the american jets
roaring overhead
nine lose about
ten or twelve americans a month here
are there more long chains in laos
uh... nothing his biggest long-chain but
there are these little c_i_a_ hideaway
is tucked in the hills there are a lot
over a couple half a dozen or so
over on the ball around spot so these
are used to trail watching me
uh... maybe something in some people
because mischief once in awhile there
there's a by the chinese border
their literally
nearly a well there are hundreds of
little dirt
runways indiana in in a while snoozing
used for military purposes by the united
states
by controlling the arms and the money
the u_s_ can affect controls the war
buildings like these house the
requirements office which is said to be
a kind of camouflaged military
assistance group
there is a variety of unarmed para
provided by paramount dot at continental
air services which are usually referred
to as c_i_a_ airlines
they admit to operating more than a
hundred planes and helicopters but they
are not as forthcoming as to be exact
nature of all their assignment
blueberry cargo and military supplies
around the country they also transport
military personnel
the people of the npr in ten dollars
have been described as the least urgent
souls bunker
to harry to be desperate or frantic the
whale westerner might be in the face of
crisis
is looked upon with national
embarrassment as a confession of human
bankruptcy
the anti on as a city that can live side
by side with its worst enemies
on one of the most locally expensive
pieces of real estate in town you find
the official residence of the communist
party at law
and its objective is nothing less than
taking over the country
and not far away another anomaly you
find a pocket loves accomplices the
embassy of north vietnam
even the north vietnamese may be a bit
perplexed to find themselves sharing a
capital with the embassy of south
vietnam just a few dusty streets away
is walls
what else is lousy but you can find the
embassy of communist china in the midst
of all this and everyone knows that
peaking help supply the guns to the part
that lyle add to the north vietnamese in
their effort to make allows a communist
state
the greater the npr on panorama is
filled with hard political economic
contract
problems will quickly agreed but they
know to allows are powerless
they are very scared
the your debt there is a warning this
country and most loved them conflict it
they shoud
they are not capable to influence
the close of
the evite
of funeral in p n_p_r_
we're cabinet ministers pilot son
it's reported by americans here that the
walls in recent months have been losing
an average of more than ten meditate
killed in action fighting the enemies
in a country of less than three million
people that's a lot of war dead
for the united states
one major priority in laos has been to
try to interdict there have been
flow of henry's men and material down
the whole chia min trail
spilling north vietnamese blood on the
trail would save american blood in south
vietnam
but the question i was whether hanoi
will follow up its latest successful
offensive in laos
there isn't an american in the country
who doesn't believe that hanoi
if it should make that critical decision
could cut through the royal our forces
and the u_s_ bombing and reach the make
on the river
what with the u_s_ do then
escalating laos
that is the agonizing question that
north vietnam complain at the courthouse
bernard kalb c_b_s_ news
the npr
at the time of the geneva agreements in
nineteen sixty two
the united states accepted principle on
a former as prime minister with some
reluctant
he was a neutral list but he seemed to
be
more neutral on the side of the
communists indeed he was their candidate
since then he has emerged as a
pro-western nationalist
if his position is not threatened by the
growing north vietnamese strengthen laws
suvarna full-blooded not admitted to
c_b_s_ news correspondent bill
mclaughlin
useful to make pull
everything
let me know falsely should not give
too much importance
assistant to this offensive
eat them all
result that we have lost man them on the
top of course we lost some ground
so far applies to all
it is not
depaz
uh... exceeded the range of normal
offensively
this all see below
support but i don't think cassette
fussing with the way north vietnam and
acting
done not because she'll gives any
indications of the not vietnam mobley
that the north vietnamese wish to
connect the u_s_
these days more deeply in the war in
indochina
would you know what the extent
of the u_s_ military involvement lawless
is you-know-what
the united states is doing
let me know life is quote the
the mambo we ask for material a
lamar we ask also for the intervention
u_s_ air force's
walks over he or surveillance against
infiltration about dates and if
necessary pple to bomb the invaders
what do you think would happen to lower
sat there was no u_s_ air support
you see
will soon be a bit we were left to
ourselves
the whole country
you gave up would come from it
two defeats the whole country would be
invaded by north vietnam listen to the
below average the duty of the united
states for technical cc
are you afraid that lowers could become
another vietnam
speeches what i've always thought
shattered to prevent lousy olson deviate
from becoming another vietnam applause
vocal that's why i've always rejected
the introduction of foreign troops
demolished
behind us are you concerned about the
activities of the central intelligence
agency in laos
but yes i cannot say anything about this
matter
prime ministers of on a former says it
is the beauty of the united states to
protect us
develop a day of that interpretation is
precisely what the current controversy
over laos is about
c_b_s_ news correspondent marvin kalb
discussed it with some concerned
senators
senator do you believe that the united
states should be in the business of
protecting lotion independent so i do
not how i don't see
wide ten thousand miles away we have to
babysit the world and job on the world
at the cost of many billions of dollars
a month in these countries
one of the same time we know at best but
we would need this money
was growing domestic problems at all
i ran out
most of my colleagues
wishes reducing gitmo
pollution in both your them and laughs
these recent activities that allows
makers have printed it
quickly we're getting
deeper involvement would be pretty well
we are
undoubtedly doing more to and uh... the
whole involvement
and than has ever been done before my
reaching beyond junction administrations
who will be only about
naturally with the president's
great success cindy escalating a
vietnamese war
it's essential for
critics to talk about something else
hence though they've grounded laos in
the hope of creating an issue there
i think is poised on trail that leads to
transparent
it's ridiculous
and in relation to lower commitments in
vietnam which i have an unfortunate
now commitments in at lower so the
different nature they are at commitments
to protect our troops in vietnam
i don't know quietly following them to
eradicate that in some parts of this
country where we think it's all right
to use five hundred bombers a day
against the country and then say it's a
very limited operation that we're going
to be careful not to put in ground
forces
i might say that that's how we get
started didn't that vietnam we had
helicopters over there every comma since
flights and advisors and
we were given assurances that we weren't
going into a land war in asia
but we've got five hundred thousand man
and on the ground now
the president and i usually i support of
our unroll it is great
andriotti is choices or
relative
i think the risk
at involved in
figure explore recruit rather
so much less
than the risk involved in
uh... the north vietnamese bigger larger
work
uh... i think the risk
district if you go out
whatever may be the ultimate intentions
of north vietnam and laos
it is clear that they have already
succeeded in disturbing the mantle of
calm with which president nixon has
wrapped the vietnam debate in this
country
the administration's dilemma arises from
the fact
that in spite of all that the united
states has been able to do for lol short
of ground combat
and always still holds the country edits
mercy
north vietnam can't take too long since
been able to do so for years had been
willing to pay the price
however
hanoi may not be a main at a military
conquest with all its legal and moral
implications and with the risk of
military over extension
north vietnam may instead be trying to
create the conditions
for a political
rather than a physical takeover
that's what popat lyle prints about my
palms invitation to discuss the new
coalition government sounds like
such a solution if it is a solution
would resent the administration with
problems only slightly less painful than
whether to introduce ground troops to
stem the tide in-laws
communist-dominated government in laos
would cause consternation and bangkok
and saigon to places where the american
commitment still rock
the north vietnamese are experts at
discovering and exploiting
contradictions in american policy
that's what they're doing now and well
they say the war there as an extension
of their war in vietnam
and they're forcing us to see it that
way too
as long as the war in vietnam content
and all i can cause us much distress
in-laws
it is an opportunity they are not likely
to forego
this is charles collingwood